[Music]
hello everybody
hope you're having a great
week i can't believe it's already been a
week time has been flying for me
i have some exciting news
personally
officially
i officially have a seat in a medical
school so i'm very happy about that i'm
still having interviews i have about
five more lined up so
we'll see how that goes
um
the other part i finally got my password
two months without passwords you know
you feel very unsafe
but personal news aside today
it's good weatherish but we don't really
have that many people here more like
it hurts a little so those of you who
are sitting in the warmth of your home
five blocks away come on get here come
on people
um
besides that thank you thank you for the
for the nice comments in the chat uh
besides that we're gonna be talking
about some truly cool non-weird i don't
think that's possible to see me play
non-weirdly but um
openings
specifically in
sicilian because that's the video series
we're doing
ah not that i said that as soon as i
said that i pictured myself holding like
a bow on top of a castle you know like
in game of thrones or something that's a
cool thumbnail i wanna i wanna talk to
someone about that
uh with peach like a mini dragon okay
but i'm getting too creative let's let's
try to stay with chess um creative
writing is not my strongest suit
so today we're going to talk about
paulson slash khan i also knew it as
paulson but people call it different
names
we are not going to really talk about
everything that's there because i don't
really
play everything that's there i'm going
to talk a lot about the bishop e2 lines
have a very brief mention on bishop d3
lines
but if you are one of those people who
enjoys playing long cast don't let me
stop you
but
this is not going to be covering the
long castle ideas
all right
let's jump right in
um
this is a big
mix of my personal games
so
i hope i don't have to prepare against
anybody playing this in the future
all right
so first things first there are some
weird starting with asics starting with
knight f6 starting with queen c7 some d6
here there are a lot of different things
that black can do so don't feel
constricted into just one line
you do not have to think of just a6 or
just knight f6 or whatnot
uh we are not going to be covering d6 to
anything with like d6 e6 tonight that's
for next week
because that's german engine
uh besides that
i do want to briefly mention asics two
more towards the end of the class
because that gets weird and i like to
end it weird
um so let's just go for knight c6
now keep in mind these knight f6 do
exist but this is what we talked about
last week so feel free to give a look to
the sicilian fortnight ideas that we
talked about last week
we talked about you know possible knight
p5s bishop out a3
blah blah it's kind of cool actually i
really liked it wait was that last week
that was last week yes sicilian four
nights
um we're gonna talk about queen c7
mostly now
to be to be fair there are knight f6 but
then you might get e5s at some points
not right now because there's a um
unfortunate check
but you know there are like if black
plays it weird there are stuff like this
so just be mindful of when if you get
the chance to play e5 as white
all right so knight c6 knight out queen
out
bishop moves ah i've missed this mouse
all right
it's very smooth it's gonna make me give
out some moves there's a question why do
i prefer e4 over d4
um
i gave d4 lines a try but i just felt
more comfortable with e4 i really liked
the
middle games of it i really liked the
the openness of the position or
um even if it was in a closed opening
such as french french
i still felt relatively comfortable so
so it's the night or for e6 instead of
wait
i said i saw something in the chat but i
guess not ah how are you doing
um fake maurice
yeah this is this one always cracks me
up
okay people have a lot of creativity all
my usernames are like dorsod 98 or pc
whatever or
all right so i personally play the
specialty 2 a lot
now to be fair g3 is pretty cool there
are ideas with bishop e3 and trying to
line
so
if you're one of the people who likes to
do anything except bishop e2
don't let me stop you but for rights now
i'm going to talk about bishop e2 so
bishop v2
pawn moves we get the beautiful castle
well i get my beautiful castle
knight f6 and i play this bishop e3 it
took me such a long time to get
comfortable in this
middle games and in this specific
structure so
this is more of an introduction for you
you will still have a lot to work on on
your own because this is a very
classical line
and there are lots of classical games
i'm thinking of a specific game of
karpov specific game equal sparrow on
there's like this um the line that we're
going to look at it's very very
um
well played and well known
so please do not just take this video
and go play it
you have to do more
um
analysis and research on it however for
the time being first things first if
opponent plays bishop v7 this kind of
turns into cheveningen because d6 will
follow so we're not going to talk about
it right now whoa
uh there's a weird b5 i'm not sure how i
feel about it
i think take is all right and then you
can i like f4 sounds reasonable to me
because you wanna start going at e5
right and then if b4 then you can go for
e5
i think that's a very reasonable
response you can also just go for knight
a4
and then try to play like c3 and try to
include your knight back in the game
that way
so there's a lot of
possibilities but i thought it's worth
mentioning
this part is worth mentioning
you can take take and
whoops not that queen d4
yeah this looks kind of cool now why do
you think queen c2 is not a good idea
let me ask first the tough questions so
if opponents where to do eat the pawn
which already looks weird but why do you
think queen takes c2 is not a good idea
i told you this would get weird i'm
incapable of showing games without
having some weird lines in there
nobody
the chat is so quiet
drop the queen that would be ideal but
that kind of feels on um
unreasonable because the queen has that
diagonal to go that diagonal to go back
way to go so i'm not so sure if trapping
the queen would exactly be
our
priority at the time being
i mean if we can do it
yeah of course i want to but i don't
think that's actually going to happen
yeah exactly black doesn't really have
that much of a development so we want to
be able to punish them for that
so i'm getting a bishop d3 suggestion
however that is not wrong bishop d1 is
something that's kind of winking at me
let's say you move the queen then then
i'll have this kind of cool check
whoops
and this is just something that i was
looking at briefly but i really kind of
don't want to exchange the queen so you
don't have to do that check at the
moment
you could simply try to be sneaky with
the rook
and just develop that's another option
or instead of bishop d1 you could
simply just go bishop f3 to avoid all
these possibilities of queen exchange
and then you're just gonna let's say
queen goes away you'll just bring your
rook
and start attacking there you'll have
f5s
i think this is very pleasant
and the engine agrees with me too so
that's another idea you can try to play
with
so
um i've never been lucky enough to have
that position happen to me however i'm
very open to it so if anybody wants to
give that a try against me please do so
lips
having long hair
okay
so
let's say opponent is reasonable and
they don't go for weird lines such as b5
so bishop b4 is the main thing to go for
again small heads up
opponent is capable of having a
different move or there to play bishop
before before castling
and that's something that you should be
aware of but um
i don't have a good game of myself to
show so i'm just giving that as i just
know it it's not that dangerous you can
um you can easily get away with it but
just just know it
all right just know that that
possibility exists
also i think it can be with a different
move over there so it can be with like a
six first knight out then queen out
bishop out
and if you go bishop e3 now they'll have
bishop b4
so this is a possibility there's so many
different transpositions
that
can get a little headachy
right now yeah like there's a bishop g5
you can also do like a
cute like bishop d2 so just be aware of
this existence of bishop before when
there's no knight on c6 okay
now that give my fair warning let's go
back to the main main main line
with bishop b4 now
so if bishop b4 now you kind of gotta go
for this knight a4 and now the opponent
has a few options
there is no one this bishop e7
there is one castle those two are the
big ones there are a bunch of other um
tiny weird lines
i've had people play like rook b8
against me or
take rights now or like b5 or whatnot so
let me actually ask you what if they do
take this right now
what is so wrong with knight taking the
pawn
um
good question from the other line that
we talked about the e4 pawn yes it does
give it up it's not a blunder it's a
sacrifice
but
yes it is a possibility for black to
accept the sacrifice
but white still is not going to be worse
so what are we thinking of now
so they take them the pawn on e4
why is this such a bad move because if
it was a good move everybody would eat
the free palms right
at least all my students hopefully would
so what are we thinking
knight takes e4
okay i'm getting maybe bishop f3 maybe
bishop d3
fair ah there we go i'm adding now we're
talking whoops bad mouse
okay
ah
okay
let's say they take over here we wanted
to we were talking about take
first off if the queen takes your idea
with queen d4 however pretty it is it
might not really
work as well as you want it to
so
first let's throw this in there then we
can try to pin this guy
point d4 will be next we're still gonna
want to do that attack
all right
so oh if the pawn takes
similar concepts we can start with queen
d4 now since there's no more queen on c6
to defend it
and this is this is relatively pleasant
so
this is a poisoned pawn opponent can not
really take it yeah
so there again there are a bunch of
other weird lines with like rook b8 for
me personally whenever i feel like i'm
not so sure how to continue in this
specific setup
i'm very fond of c4 just because this
kind of
transposes to maroxy lines myoxyplum
structures
and opponent is just
very um
misplaced
even if they castle right now oh maybe i
can actually try to trap the bishop by
c5 there we go
yeah i got stuff going on here too
um
now
see for example like if opponent plays a
totally random move that's a possibility
um
d6 is also not a good choice why do you
think d6 is not a good choice
when's it back i guess wait i don't
think we're talking about the same
position anymore
yeah smirky sparky pants um funny
username you
it's you have to know what you're doing
as black there there are many many
tricky lines there but you like you
truly have to know your opening you
can't just
play it and learn while playing when it
comes to
some of these theory
c4 i'm sure c4 is doable too but it
makes more sense to
start kicking the bishop because my
knights here
can actually um
get the bishop right and i can give you
weird pawn structures
maybe then f3
yeah and then i have two bishops
semi-open center voila
exactly tangy island the black bishop is
relatively misplaced and i completely
agree with that so let's talk about
maybe castle first
what do you think we should do
i have two personal games
in
this database but i have
much more
i've analyzed this so much more than i
ever played it
which is
hurtful i need more opponents playing
this against
me but
why to move what do you think we should
do
so what's the hype about c3 i don't get
it
i guess i'm seeing so many c3 in chat
hmm
nope we don't want to go bishop d3
not just yet anyways
okay i'm um yeah c3 does not right now
it doesn't make much sense c4 is very
interesting c4 is very doable as well
now if they take it
again
you can try to
mess with the special i was gonna say
trap it but then i realized trapping is
not the exact
right thing to say it's just messing
with the bishop at this point
because again you can't really take it
right
beautiful
bye-bye bishop party
and so yes we are capable of trying to
trap this bishop if the bishop tries to
run
now i can bring it even harder if they
try to run now i get another pin the
concept of tempo and initiative here is
just
screaming at us
okay let me ask you we have one last
pawn now what do you think we should do
we have two beautiful bishops opponent
has two well this one is kind of pretty
but one
tall pawn on their eighth rank
so
white tumor what do you think we should
do
i'm getting a knight to b6 option
suggested
possible
what else do you got
somebody's suggesting nice c3 and then
they're correcting themselves i love it
totally i'm totally loving people
correcting themselves makes my job so
much more easier
so much more pleasant too
i mean this is still kind of nice for
whites but yeah we don't wanna we don't
want we do not want happy opponents
okay so i'm getting a queen b3
suggestion
doable but queen c2 makes more sense
just bring more pressure
now if like forget f7
we can bring this
then you can try to bring this
you can just keep the pressure because
black cannot develop these two pieces
easily
so while they can't develop you can try
to develop as much as you can
so this is more of a waiting game at
this point
but a beautiful one and this is already
plus two for white at least so
this is again a poisoned pawn opponent
cannot easily take it
so what if they go like
bishop d6 right
now
oh that's such a hard question
somebody's asking in the chat is the
sicilian khan better than the karo khan
i'm not sure if that's a pun because
there's both khan and there's khan in
both of them
but
chess wise they're
they're too different
it really depends what type of middle
games what type of pawn structures what
type of centers do you prefer to play
so
i feel like it's more about your own
experiences with that game
so
good luck figuring that out for yourself
in this day and age you don't actually
need to read
50 books to figure it out you can watch
a video or two and see if you feel
comfortable playing this as white or as
black
so
oh there's a question is the khan like
the paulson
i always use them interchangeably but i
feel like there the question is with the
when you play a6 or when you play knight
c6 but
i feel like it just transposes a lot
all right so good thing somebody's
suggesting f4 well if f4 now what if
they just eat your pond
then what do you do
i'm not very big a fan of f4 i'm
generally a f4
enthusiast
but not in this situation in this
situation g3 is more forced
so because we want to be able to follow
it up with c5
and if bishop tries to go away
now you're going to continue with your
same ideas of developments that we
talked about possibly with the addition
of knight to b6 at some point as well
but again a lot of this game is about
a space and your pizza your own piece
activity
so
if you are somebody who prefers a more
safe options then i don't think this
opening is for you
but if you're fine being
one pawn down and having this amazing of
a position
space wise and peace activity clients
then you're in the right place
just to illustrate what i'm trying to
show you let's look at this position
from white's perspective i'm going to
flip the board real quick and look at it
as blacks
you can kind of already see white has so
much more
investment in the game than the black
does
so
yeah
well i miss playing over the board
tournaments because one of my favorite
things to do was to actually get up go
behind the opponent and see what they
see
it's not you know i'm not trying to
go stand behind them and hum or poke
them with a
sharp nail or whatever
please never do that but like just just
actually seeing how do they feel about
their position what do they see
so that's that's kind of a fun thing you
can try to do when you start playing
over the board tournaments too
well patrick you're more than welcome to
try to give another one for compensation
too all right
c4 is a definite possibility but for me
c4 is a little sharper than i'm
usually comfortable with again depending
on the situation of the tournament like
if it's the last round that i need to
win well more for c4
but um
yeah knight takes c6 is another
completely comfortable
idea now
first things what if the queen takes
i'm just asking you questions what if
the queen takes that keep in mind this
is a double attack
what would we do
drink a gallon of red bull and play e5
well i might actually know somebody who
does
drink that much red bull the one thing i
miss i i can't really find a specific
red bull in the u.s it was like five six
years ago i was in russia in contempt
and they had this really cool red bulls
that had like a uh like a lid that you
could like screw and then close i loved
it because i would never finish the
whole thing and i could use it you know
a few hours later but now here is just
all can and it's just hurtful so
if you guys find that specific red bull
that you can actually
open the lid and close it back up do let
me know i i do want it
but
yeah
all right where were we
ah
so i'm getting some c3s in chat some
nice c trees in chat some night b6 in
chats
they got discontinued
why
this is hurtful okay
i've never seen it in the us though just
saying
yeah i'm not i'm not big on c3
it's all right but you're kind of
pushing opponents bishop to go to a
better spot
and you all know how i feel about
helping opponents
i feel good about it
so instead of c3 how about we actually
do the move with the tempo which is
super forceful then we do another move
that is forceful and then this guy gotta
move
and then
question
what's now
are we forced into actually exchanging
that light off
or
do we have another option
bishop f3 ah interesting but what if
they still take it and attack your queen
um i don't think this works and it's
kind of funny because i'm seeing more
than just one person in chat saying it's
he
yeah i know bishop of three just um it's
a blunder sorry people
yeah you gotta take this horsey
they take back and then we get bishop f3
now this is falling
no way to stop it
comfortable enough
yep
yeah i'm comfortable in this i'm very
happy with this position actually an
engine loves it too just fyi black is
very
underdeveloped the pieces are just
misplaced
so
let's go back
not queen takes c6 what if d takes it
this is not a bad move
but it's a very
uncommon move
ah something to b6
possibly
i'm still kind of thinking of the c4 c5
though
let's say c4 and if they take this now
we get c5 and this bishop is busted
if they go away
this is a
bishop bust right yeah
so this is kind of what i want
i want to play tricky i want to leave
poisonous stuff for our opponent
over the chessboard just to clarify
good god
um
yeah
wait there's a question bishop d3 does
it work now um
are you talking about right now this
should be three it's totally doable but
this bishop here is active so why not
try to punish it for a dreaming big
you know which objection not a bad move
but what if they go b5 then you're going
to have to move this knight and they can
try to you know
try to trade it try to gain some
activity around here
so my idea is to try to prevent these
from happening that's kind of like my
priority right now
so c4 does make sense
now if you go away with the bishop now i
can
quincy too looks appealing
um
bishop d3 i think now it's time though
c5 then knight c3
b6 maybe to get this one out
then we can't go this way but it's still
you know
it's very doable but at the same time
it's a little bit dressier than what i
was kind of going for
oh come on patrick
i'm never gonna do something like that
all right
uh
all right all right so let's just talk
about the main line d takes now what do
we do
nice one one dorsal sex
palms there's trouble in the air
not necessarily i i i'm quite stingy
with my material but at the same time i
try to keep a friendly environment over
the board
i would just want to be tricky like hey
if you want to eat it
i'll just
get a little bit more
space maybe threat on your king a little
just just a little
all right so this is a big main line
what do we do here
oh i love it f4 is a great idea
and
i tried this knights b6
rook moves
take takitaki
and then there's this like cool bishop
a6
i gave it a try
and it's all right but at the same time
um
you eat this one pawn but then your
opponent starts attacking and they'll
gain the pawn back
and i wasn't very comfortable i did give
this a try i was not not my
thing i wanted more
for my ponds than
just being eaten
what would i say is my favorite sicilian
variation ooh
cheveningen
those two are always kind of cool
dragon is fine too but not my top choice
top five choice
it's too too sharp for both sides and
it's too much theory for both sides
and it's
hard to understand
to be able to actually
uh
play
without the theory
so
all right f4 is totally cool
and
this is one game that i played but this
was a specific preparation oh wait i
think this girl was actually american
um this game that i'm showing with this
f4 bishop d3 i played against i believe
alice dung
back in 2013
in the world youth championship in alain
i did win the game thank you
but um
yeah i think she was american she is
american probably question mark
if my memory serves well
anywho i'm gonna show you this game
really quick because i just want you to
see
what a great preparation can do for you
okay
so
let's go for this
okay maybe not for that per se
but
i wanted to play solid
and then i wanted to be able to open up
my bishop
and then i continued by making sure
opponent can't do much in the queen side
as well because i don't want to
leave my queen side b and then just go
attacking the king side and then the
attack fails and the queen side is
not looking that
happy so
take take
and she went for c5
i continued by rook c1
maybe slight inaccuracy but i was fine
with it
and
all right
now i'm switching the gear i still want
to
hope for an attack but if i can eat c5
pawn i'm fine too
what is the
ah
it is it can be solid it can be dynamic
it truly depends on what
white plays with white blah what black
plays how white responds how black
responds it's a lot of different um
ways to see this
okay
queen c6 was played
and i just started to
enjoy this attack
now this was a bad move i didn't play
the best move possible
what do you think is the best move for
whites right now
and i feel like ben feingold
when somebody when my opponent played f6
probably he would um
be very unhappy
how do you get better at chess well
first things first you're in the right
place
for the san luis chess club youtube
channel
you're here you're you're doing it
calculation is a big part of it though
it's not just openings but
yeah thank you people f5 yes
then the king moved you can boom that
they boom this you can boom that they
come over here then you can boom the
other one
this is too much fun
but i was a baby this was
eight years ago
and
as i did not play a five i did not have
the same chess philosophy that i have
now and i just want to play something a
little more solid so i went for h3
basically i chickened out to put it um
lightly
and then i just started to be like no no
i don't want a chicken out i still want
to attack
and
my opponent
helped me but
my position is the thing is my position
was good enough that i had the luxury of
playing a little um
less accurate than i would be happy
right now
but the position is good i have stable
advantage with the pawn on c5 i have
stable
advantage because my pieces are
more activated but yes
okay okay so opponent drake there i
brought the bishop back
a little switch switch
and
i started to do that and now this is
just winning at this point beautiful
checkmate good job
okay come on dorsa why did you do that
just take it over here come on man
i just i just gave myself a pat on the
back but i didn't take a beautiful check
it's all right
yeah anyways um this is still super
winning to be to be to be clear okay
short just good enough
and
then i started to
play a little weird why did i do this
anyways this is still good i'm still
better much better to be clear
but you can easily see how my chest
philosophy was different
eight years ago then now
but yeah this the position was good
enough so i didn't have just one moves
to do to win it but i you know i would i
would not want this for you
all right so here uh my opponent
resigned i had a decent tournament
in the to the best of my memory but i
didn't really
go in the middle which is still a little
sore
alright let's go back i just wanted to
show you another opportunity i'm going
to actually go a lot back
another lot back
yeah so i wanted to show you that this
f4 is totally doable and it's kind of
funny as i'm talking about it i'm
actually remembering when i was
preparing it it was like a weird
university dorm room that's the
tournament was being hosted at so i was
um
i remember like i was sitting in like a
corner and i was preparing this
and for some reason i'm craving cereal
right now anyways
there's a lot of cereal in that
university doing rooms
so f4 completely possible
however
knight b6 isn't still
what i play more frequently these days
opponents can take with queen as well
but this is this kind of it gets a
little
less
comfortable
but this is totally doable too
i'm just presenting multiple options to
you
if you wanted to play this bishop a6 you
should know what you're doing
because you are gaining a pawn but at
the same time
your opponent gets to be
um
a little more tacky than i'm comfortable
with
because this is a weak pawn this is a
weak pawn the bishop can go back here
attack that pawn let's say you even play
the perfect bishop to d3 and then
they'll go bishop d6 and then they're
attacking this they're attacking that
and um
just be aware
okay
now let's talk about another big line of
not castle but bishop e7 now in this one
you got to take
they take knight b6 your b8 you take
they take now if here they get weird and
they take with drug please do eat this
and say thank you
if we're close to v8 you can just come
back here if they take this your rook is
behind this pawn so start running with
it
and say thank you for me leave a comment
below if this ever happens
all right
so
not
um i don't think anybody as black would
take that with the rook unfortunately so
let's say queen tanks now question for
the audience
i'm assuming some of you already know
this opening some of you don't so i
think it's a good mix
right now why to move what you got to do
you have two reasonable options one of
them is my personal favorite the other
one is still pretty doable
what you think
patrick that's true there's like it's
more tempting to keep your a b2 pawn
than the h2
i understand that
oh g4 r
jesus why am i getting so many g4s
what did i do to deserve this g4
keep in mind your opponent is attacking
e4 and b2
so you might want to
take a deep breath
breath
so you're suggesting queen d3
or e5 ah
or bishop d4
all right i think i can live happily
with e5 or bishop d4
so kind of up to you which one do you
think we should
we should look for
i'm i'm a bigger fan of bishop d4
because knight e4 does not really scare
me i live for this chaos
boom
exactly
and i actually had one or two really
cool blitz game in this and it's so
nuts it's just like it's bananas raining
all over the board and you can't it's
just like it's amazing for blitz but
if you actually do know
your um if you have the option to
prepare
for a specific game for a specific
opponent just make sure you do that
before you go to the game it will you'll
thank me later but
yeah this is one of those lines that
it's just going to be a
weird left and right and
raining bananas and
whatever so what nuts not whatever
so
all right
i love my brain i do not want my brain
to
come out of my ears right now so we're
not gonna go over this line but if you
play this you gotta know it
oh there's a full question how many
moves in advance do you usually
calculate before playing a move
it really depends on the game and games
are usually the easier because there's
less possibilities
but
um
it really it just really depends on how
comfortable i'm with the middle game how
much i know about that
specific type of middle game
there's another question oh how long
have i been playing this
you mean this
game or this line this game 17 years 35
countries
and i know it's because i've actually
been writing secondaries
applications and all those about it for
the past
almost a year
so
i know it's my 17th year of involvement
in chess
here's 17 more to come
alright
now i just wanted to mention this knight
d4 exists
now as black this is something that you
could possibly prepare
to try to see how much your opponent
knows because if the opponent doesn't
uh worship chaos then that's this this
knight takes e4 is going to be very
uncomfortable for them because they have
to
deal with your king in the center but
they can't really attack it as much as
they want it
uh we actually did a video i believe
last year about should you castle i did
a video about that and i think there was
a game of magnus or two that we talked
that we kind of talked about she didn't
castle he hit an amazing game so you
don't need castle to be able to play an
amazing game
all right oh there's a question yum
yummy so there there's a question about
why doesn't he point knight c5 instead
of f5
oh here
uh
because i don't want to give up the pawn
i'm assuming
yeah that'll do yep all right well thank
you for the question it's always better
to ask than to wonder
all right all right so number 94 94 is
about possibility but at the same time
completely up to you how much you
worship chaos
all right
so
um
let's go back
so let's say they go for the good move
of c5
now
what should you do
it's bishop still got to be able to
protect this guy the knight is still
attacking this pawn so where do we go
what do we do
i don't think bishop takes f6 as a
candidate because then the bishop will
take it then the b2 pawn will still
suffer a lot
and why would i actually give up my two
bishops
there we go this should be five you got
this yep rook b6
and then what do you think we should do
there is a a b3 which is doable but
that's not the line that i chose to play
and also not the idea
not the classic idea
and
small heads up you can
find
pretty
pretty cool games in
this
position
as white and as black
so just
be aware of that
opportunity being there
okay
yeah queen d3 is what i want
and how do i get rid of those errors
ah that's what i was thinking about yeah
there is a nice game of
kasparov anand shirafonant
another game of kasparov
these are like maybe 20 year old games
game of like
um chris chuck versus polgar shirov also
saw massey oh my god there's so many
amazing games so
there's a lot of cool games here okay
[Music]
queen d3 is indeed the best one
my opponent went for d6 now why not d5
what do you think is actually wrong with
d5 possibly
so what if this d5 happens
you don't have to have a specific move
ready
but
yeah pedro i was trying to see the the
master games to try to name some name
drop some cool names and i keep wanting
to carpool but
but i i can't remember i know what anna
and kasparov played this
a lot
okay
yep easy peasy
you don't want to take this just yet
because if you take and then you take
this will fall anyways but you can
definitely take this part if the knights
take swell then yummy yummy if the pawn
takes then you might have bishop of
threes and start attacking it that way
so you have a bunch of different options
that i want you to consider
so
feeling good
all right so let's go back back back
i think i actually played this bishop f3
once and i was like why did this happen
like i didn't fully understand why my
position got a little uncomfortable
and i'm gonna show you why
because now my opponent actually started
to
get what they wanted and my bishop was a
little out of place here
and i still had a pleasant game
but
it's it started to get a little messy
and it was be getting harder and harder
to actually
uh
gain any any advantages
so yeah maybe mindful of that
all right let's go back i do not
recommend bishop f3
any longer i like this queen d3 d6 you
gotta come back with the bishop and now
what
now
let's say i wanted castles
you have multiple options one of them is
b3
one of them is rook d1
i'm going to open my
database of the master games i don't
know why i call it air quality but the
concept of
master games is kind of funny for me
i always
used
chess bass
rather than leeches so i'm very much
used to that
software and
the different
different softwares but
okay
not scared of ed5 maybe queen g3 ah
queen g3 so maybe
maybe for later
okay i see a lot of you are suggesting
queen g3 but what would you do with d5
yeah i'm not so sure what would you
choose if d5 so
all right so not d5
not queen g3 so rook d1 is nice
b3 is nice peter is more desired because
this is a problem why should i give my
opponent that point of pride to be able
to bother me with that tiny pawn well
i'm going to move it
and have an evil laughter
i wish i could do evil laughters or i
had a button
i'm still gonna request that button
small button of like evil laughter
thank you thank you who should i ask
anyways
um
what's my favorite opening i'm gonna go
ahead and say scotch
but i'm also going to clarify that i
don't like it as a drink so
okay
now b3 is good i'm i'm fond of b3 now
queen c6 was actually played in a game
with me and there's nothing wrong with
it you did played it
so
let's see actually let me scroll down
i'm gonna see if i can name drop a few
other cool names
um there are a few cool names but
not a world champion unfortunately
am i right all right
queen c6 is nice but let me go back go
back bad mouse
d5 is very common as well
and for example anand played this as
black
uh mossy played this as black oh good
friend drop words played this as black
and a bunch of other big names
but so for d5 it happened to me
frequently as well d5 e5 is a good
choice
sorry
and then the knight moves you're going
to
swift the rook
you can also be more
aggressive and bring in the queen
f4 is another possibility which is very
desired if c4 then you gotta take it
though so
i was not very happy with this idea i
still want to do f4 but i want to be
able to
not be forced into dealing with c4 as
soon as i would
all right so queen g3 is something that
i would recommend for you to play
if rook c6 right now
then you can go ahead and simply develop
this is a comfortable position this is
coming up
hopefully
um another thing to be mindful of
is
after this e5 there is a knight e4 but
then you can just move the bishop the
rook moves and then you just kind of
mess with the structure a little and
then this kind of a nice target for you
as well oh there's a question about what
if queen g3 they played f6
what if i just go f4
hmm
i have disabled that thank you this is
different because i'm actually going
from the top games
i'm trying to give suggestion from there
because
i really really thought there was a nice
kasparov anand game out here but i can't
see it ah there it is actually
all right
let's close this
okay so for example in kasparov anand
in 2000 they took
and then take then they got themselves
into this position which is again pretty
comfortable but that's not what i wanted
i wanted to be able to close up and
attack that way so if you want to
actually be able to attack attack then
this exchange will will not be for you
yeah
there's not much left to do at this
point okay let's go back
oh i see some stuff in the chat
yes yes
thank you i'm annie
all right all right so let me talk about
my personal game with this queen c6 as
well
then i went for bishop f3 because i
still want to get f4 but my opponent is
not letting me
i could be pushed into e5 but then
knight d5 and then i would have to take
and then they could take and it would
get another kind of weird so i i like
this idea of bishop f3 knight goes away
now small moves
to be fair this is good too but i did
just didn't want to do rook d1 because i
the
or the other d1 same concept because
there's this c4 that i was hoping to
avoid because now if i take there's
knights e5
if i take with queen take take and again
this will get too easy for opponent so
in order to try to keep some
spark
in the game
i wanted to
to exchange as less as possible
so we got
ourselves into this position oh god i
remember this this was a game that i
played in gibraltar oh this was never
gonna end i managed to win it but oh my
god this was such a long game you see
you have advantage because of the pawn
structure but you can't really do much
about it because
okay i actually tried to do a little
about it
because this two versus three and the
opposite pawns oh good god it's never
gonna end so
this is another
option for you out there
the only way that i would say you could
consider doing differently
if you wanted instead of b3 was district
d1
but you still have to be mindful because
yes you want to bring the coin to the
other side and start
attacking but opponent is also preparing
for d5 opponent also wants to maneuver
upon and also wants to do stuff in the
queen side so
it's a very
very complicated position
you don't have clear advantage but it
feels like you do
a plant doesn't have clear plants
but
they have some ideas that they can do in
the queen side somebody doesn't have to
[ __ ] you in the king side
but yeah it got really boring someday i
might actually show you that game on how
i had to play
however long it was like
60 something moves to be able to
actually at the end of the opponent's
blundered
but it was just such a drawish game
and i remember the exhaustion
but i won it's all that matters
uh anyways
i'm gonna kind of leave you with this
the idea that there is if you play good
and your opponent plays good you're both
going to get into a position that there
are some options for use options for
opponents and at the end of the day the
more chess you know the more skills you
have
the more chances you have a winning so
not everything is opening we use
openings to get to a comfortable middle
game
we get we want to get to a position that
we kinda know how to play and ideally we
are comfortable more comfortable in that
position than our opponent is so i
presented
multiple ideas on how to play
against main lines of con
paulsen we're still going to continue
looking into some tiny weird lines of
con pulsing next week
and then start moving it to shivan again
and then after that my door and then do
it full circle back to dragon and
browser and session go but we're never
going to end this series are we
but
um i do check your comments so please do
feel free to leave your ideas and your
recommendations and questions
and
anything else below don't forget to
subscribe and one final note
uh do join us on twitch shortly because
we're gonna do the switch to twitch and
analyze your games so
perfect
see you there
[Music]
you